numer of science scientific Studies have
shown that as human beings we're
terrible at actually being able to
predict accurately our emotional states
we tend to see those emotional states as
being way more intense than what they're
going to be and Lasting way longer than
what they're going to be too and so that
becomes a bit of an issue as well as I
call making emotional mountains out of
mole Hills right like it's usually not
that bad once you get started but it's
easy to convince yourself it's going to
be really bad yeah yeah yeah but that's
but what we're what we're doing is we're
experiencing those emotions we're time
traveling ahead and thinking that those
emotional states are going to be really
difficult and and they never really
are